. So let's now get into more of this bizarre
interview that Donald Trump did with Fox Business
host Maria Bartiromo this morning.
The big news from this interview was that
Donald Trump will not debate Joe Biden next
week.
As of right now, because the Commission on
Presidential Debates decided it would be a
virtual debate, Trump doesn't want it.
That was the sort of big headline.
But as this interview went on, Donald Trump
was making less and less sense, shouting things
out that had nothing to do with what Maria
Bartiromo was asking about.
And once again, raising the question about,
is Trump manic because of his use of dexamethasone?
Is Trump simply desperate because his polling
has imploded?
Does Trump think yelling about Hillary on
Fox News will help his poll numbers?
We don't know the answers to any of these
questions, but I'm going to give you a small
sampling of what went on here.
But what is abundantly clear is this is not
a well person here.
Donald Trump claims that he recovered from
Corona virus so quickly because he's a perfect
physical specimen.
And then they just start talking over each
other.
They being Donald Trump and the interviewer,
Maria Bartiromo, tell me tell me how you felt,
what you went through.
It's amazing to me that you're back in such
strong form right now.
How did that happen when talking about Regeneron?
Eli Lilly and Regeneron want FDA approval
for emergency use at this point.
Are they going to.
And they're going to get it?
Yeah, they're going to get it.
I'm back because I'm a perfect physical specimen
and I'm extremely young.
And so I'm lucky in that way.
And you know what?
We are I don't have any I don't have heart
problems.
I don't have diabetes.
I don't have any of the problems that you
read about perhaps a couple of pounds we could
lose here and there.
You know, there's a lot of people in that
category.
But, no, I'm in good health.
And, you know, look look, what happens is
if you're anywhere around this thing, you
can catch it.
And there's the big realization.
Trump finally understands contagion.
Isn't that amazing?
If you're round it anywhere, if it's anywhere
around you, you can catch it.
It's like seven or eight months since this
started.
And Trump finally understands if someone with
the virus is anywhere around you, you might
catch the virus.
An incredible learning experience for Trump.
Hasn't it been a Trump on the Joe Biden town
hall?
I guess that Joe Biden did with Lester Holt
a few days ago.
Trump very angry about it, but it's not totally
clear what he's talking about here.
NBC disaster, where he went on the show with
Lester Holt.
It was like it was meant for a child.
It wasn't meant for a grown person.
He gets up, he says, we're not fracking, we're
not fracking.
He was fracking for six months.
He was fracking.
He was raising his his very thin hand and
he was fracking.
And now all of a sudden, he's not fracking.
We'll tell the Pennsylvania people that you're
going.
It's ridiculous.
He said he's not fracking, raising his very
thin hand.
It's not even possible to guess what this
man is talking about here.
Trump then accuses China of putting a curse
on the United States.
Take a listen to this.
It wasn't our worker's fault.
It wasn't our airlines fault that China did
this terrible thing to us.
That I will not be forgetting about that China
did this.
This is all done by China.
And we shouldn't be hurting our workers because
China put the curse on because this was a
horrible score, a horrible, horrible thing
that they did.
So the virus went from a biological agent
released by a Chinese lab months ago.
That was their idea months ago.
Now it's simply a curse.
So sort of going from a conspiracy to the
occult.
Trump then calls for Barack Obama and Joe
Biden to be indicted for crimes, which, of
course, he can never enumerate unless Bill
Barr indicts these people for crimes that
the greatest political crime in the history
of our country.
Then we're going to get a little satisfaction
unless I win and we'll just have to go because
I won't forget it.
But these people should be indicted.
This was the greatest political crime in the
history of our country.
And that includes Obama and it includes Biden.
These are people that spied on my campaign.
And we have everything now.
They say they have much more.
OK.
And they say, Bill.
Notice that Donald Trump still, after all
these months of saying biggest political crime
in history, we caught them.
We have all the evidence.
Obama and Biden did it to me.
Donald Trump still is unable to tell us exactly
what laws were broken, exactly what crimes
Barack Obama and Joe Biden committed.
But when you talk about my political enemies
should be indicted.
That's something we're used to hearing from
other countries.
But but not so much from ours except under
Donald Trump.
Then Trump, bizarrely, says he's killed terrorists
who are bigger names than Osama bin Laden.
It's all what, celebrity fetishism with Trump.
Take a listen to this.
We have the greatest troops in the world.
I wiped out 100 percent of the ISIS caliphate.
I killed Sulimani.
I killed al Baghdadi.
Names and everybody, bigger names.
And Osama bin Laden.
Al-Baghdadi founded ISIS.
Everything is hyperbole.
Everything is superlative.
With this guy, bigger names than Osama bin
Laden, it's always been about, can I do more?
Can I do it better?
Can I do it bigger than Barack Obama?
And then it really got wacky.
Trump reacting to last night's vice presidential
debate between Joe Biden, between Mike Pence,
rather, and Kamala Harris.
And Trump says of Kamala.
She is a communist.
And then with no shred of sarcasm or joking
at all, says that Joe Biden wouldn't make
it two months as president.
Seems like he's talking health wise.
Industry here.
What was your reaction to the debate?
What wasn't said that you would have liked
to come out?
And where do you think the most striking moments
were?
I thought that wasn't even a contest last
night.
She was terrible.
She was.
I don't think you could get worse and totally
unlikable than she is.
She's a communist.
She's left a Bernie.
She's rated left out Bernie by everybody.
She's a communist.
We're gonna have a communist and she's gonna
be it, in my opinion, within a month.
Look, I sit next to Joe and I looked at Joe.
Joe's not lasting two months as president.
OK.
That's my opinion.
Joe Biden won't last two months, says Donald
Trump, of course, without any evidence.
And remember, Trump is the one that's sick
right now.
And that came up as well on the issue of Trump
having coronavirus.
Trump says he hasn't been tested for a corona
virus recently, but that he is essentially
very clean.
He says, well, that of the Senate hearing
that he was supposed to do this president.
No, you have to go.
Just to recap, you're not going to do the
next debate because it's virtual.
You're feeling good.
I know.
I want to make sure that the audience understands
you're feeling good.
Have you been tested recently?
Can you tell us anything else?
Certain.
But I'm I'm essentially very clean.
They say it's over a period of six, seven
days.
And I was you know, it's an amazing thing
happened to me.
I just went in and I didn't feel good.
And that's OK.
I expected at some point because I'm out there.
I've got to be a leader.
I can do you know, Winston Churchill didn't
sit in his basement for six months.
I got a lot of things doing.
I'm essentially very clean.
Famous last words from Donald Trump.
One really wild thing.
As Maria Bartiromo tries to end the interview.
This is wild.
Trump yells out of nowhere.
Why hasn't Hillary Clinton been indicted?
He just yells out out of nowhere.
Well, I'd like to go back to the White House
soon to do another interview.
Mr. President, I have to go back to the White
House.
I saw Hillary Clinton being invited for terminating
33000 emails that she got from Congress.
Congress made a request to see him.
Everybody else I know gets indicted when they
don't give that they don't give a shit to
destroy 33000 e-mails.
Forget about the fact that there were classified.
Let's go.
Maybe Mike Pompeo finally finds them.
The interview was over.
As far as Maria Bartiromo was concerned, Donald
Trump interrupts and yells out, why hasn't
Hillary Clinton been indicted yet?
It's sort of a fitting conclusion to a completely
absurd interview.
And we are seeing a desperate Trump.
Yes, the steroids may be affecting his behavior.
Yes, he still doesn't sound good.
He sounds hoarse, struggling to breathe.
But there is desperation here because Donald
Trump on some some level must realize half
his campaign team has coronavirus.
He's down in the polls.
He blew it in that first debate.
He may now not even be participating in the
second debate.
He must feel like this is slipping through
his fingers like sand.
And he's desperate.
And this is what we see when Donald Trump
gets desperate.